F3: We have a voicemail number, which you can
call if you have anything to tell me and many
of you do. That number is two one nine two David
P. Here is a question about vaccine distribution
and the Chinese coronavirus vaccine. Let's listen.
M13: And in many places like the Philippines,
so they're being left out to die by Americans
because they say the American vaccines and
so many countries are actually trying
to scale back the vaccine from China.
What are your thoughts on the sentiment of
being abandoned? Secondly, can we really
trust the central bank vaccine approved by
the CCP, considering what the CCP doing is
doing to wiggers, to them, Hong Kong, etc.?
F3: Yeah, so there's two questions there.
First of all, the hoarding of vaccines by
certain countries. I mean, listen, yeah,
it's going on. It's completely predictable and
at least internally logical that if you are the
government of the United States, you would first
try to get enough vaccines for the United States.
The counter argument that's being made is the
U.S. has secured way more vaccines than the
U.S. actually needs for three hundred and thirty
million people. That's true. The U.S. doesn't have
nearly all of those vaccines. And some of those
contracts, I believe, are sort of backstops, you
know, securing 100 million extra doses of the JMJ
vaccine in case Pfizer and or Moderna don't come
through. The U.S. has already said anything extra
we're going to start giving to other countries. So
this is a tough situation because countries are
going to try to vaccinate their own people first.
That that makes perfect sense. The question
becomes when there's disproportionate market
power, when there are dramatically different
financial situations, at what point is the
behavior considered predatory? And that's sort of
an ongoing debate. Now, the question about can we
trust the Chinese vaccine? I mean, listen, I don't
know the who's going to decide whether to approve
it. The Chinese vaccine from from Sino vaccine,
a vaccine. AVAC is a conventional vaccine rather
than an MRI, and it has the advantage that it
can be stored in a standard fridge instead of
requiring a particularly cold fridge. The efficacy
is unclear. The data we have so far from trials in
Turkey and Indonesia, the Turkey trial says it's
ninety one percent effective. The Indonesia trial
says it's sixty five percent effective. That's
pretty different. Is it because of different
variant strains? It's just not clear yet.
Researchers in Brazil said the Chinese vaccine
is 78 percent effective. But then they revised the
data and said, oh, it's only 50 percent effective.
I don't know and I have no special opinion
about it. You know, the Sputnik vaccine didn't
go through nearly as rigorous testing before
approval. It was approved in Russia before
being as extensively tested with completed
stage three, phase three trials as in the U.S.
But from what we know now, it does appear
to be safe and effective by and large.
So I think the question is a perfectly fair one.
I think the answer needs to be guided by the data
and we will see what the show decides. Now, there
are some who will say the show is so embedded with
China and the CCP, the Chinese Communist Party,
that we can't even trust the shows determination
on this vaccine. I don't know. I don't know.
I think it's a fair question. And we'll have
more data coming very, very soon. And efficacy
aside, if we believe the early data, it is like
the other vaccines, almost 100 percent effective
at preventing serious covid and death. So we will
see what the next couple of weeks bring on the
bonus show. Today, we are going to talk about
the conflict happening in some European countries,
about the AstraZeneca Oxford vaccine, where some
places have said we're pausing this vaccine
because of some blood clots, whereas others
are saying there is no evidence that the blood
clots are connected to the vaccine in any way.
We'll talk about that on today's bonus show. We
will also talk about the governor of West Virginia
wants a population boom in the state of West
Virginia and also wants a Disney theme park.
And the plan is to cut taxes. It's all very weird.
We'll talk about West Virginia, a state not often
discussed on the show. And we will also talk
about Russia's forthcoming blockage of Twitter.
Russia says they will block Twitter nationally in
the country unless Twitter deletes banned content.
And what are the implications? What are
the motivations? And we will talk about
that on today's bonus show. How do you
get access to the bonus show? It's easy.
You go to join Pakman dot com and you sign
up. That's it. We have a coupon code. The
code is better. Twenty one. It'll save you some
money. You're not obligated to use it, but you
could be listening or watching, listening to
or watching today's bonus show in 60 seconds.
M3: If you get a membership at Genpact and
Dotcom. Otherwise, I'll see you back here.